[Música]
Bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de France 24 soy herminia Fernández
comenzamos
de un lado de la frontera Haití el país
más pobre de América Latina y el Caribe
consumido por la violencia y la
deficiencia de sus instituciones del
otro República Dominicana el país que ha
tenido el mayor crecimiento de las
Américas Durante los últimos 20 años
atrayendo flujos de capitales que
despertarían la envidia de cualquier
jefe de estado los divide una frontera a
través de la que se intercambian
toneladas de mercancías legales o
ilegales por donde también circulan
decenas de miles de trabajadores esta
frontera ahora será reforzada por un
muro que comenzó a construirse por orden
del ex presidente dominicano Danilo
Medina y que será terminada por su
sucesor y actual mandatario Luisa
vidaner La idea es contener toda forma
de tráfico el proyecto de construcción
ha sido considerado como humillante del
lado Hai y provocará una reconfiguración
completa del estilo de vida de las
poblaciones fronterizas nuestros
corresponsales la hora es cubilea y
Mateo comín recorrieron esta frontera de
norte a sur aquí la historia
[Música]
este bebé acaba de nacer y lucha por
sobrevivir Oye seguro el bebé puede
fallecer alta probabilidad de fallecer
por sufrimiento fetal agudo lo pongo sin
nombre
viene sin ninguna documentación nosotros
no sabemos las condiciones clínicas ni
de la madre
su madre haitiana llegó a esta clínica
de República Dominicana después de haber
cruzado la frontera un largo trayecto
hecho a pie en pleno trabajo de parto
incluso antes de nacer el bebé ya estaba
agotado pero este pequeño hospital de la
ciudad fronteriza de pedernales carece
de medios para salvarlo lo tengo un
estado crítico fue imposible la
intubación
estoy aquí apurada si el niño se queda
aquí alta probabilidad de fallecer para
que por favor me ayude con el traslado
un espacio donde sea
una situación frecuente a lo largo de
una frontera que separa Haití el país
más pobre de las Américas y República
Dominicana la economía más dinámica de
la misma zona una franja de 376
kilómetros que comienza aquí un estuario
que se puede cruzar a pie un simple
bolardo marca la división en este
paisaje apacible pero si se viaja por el
río 15 km hacia el sur medirá 200
kilómetros
el gobierno dominicano fue el impulsor
del proyecto y la gran mayoría de la
población lo apoyo
[Música]
incluso las personas que se verán
gravemente afectadas Mildred es Ganadera
el muro estamos Totalmente de acuerdo
con la seguridad
del país y de la ciudadanía este terreno
era superado el gobierno dominicano
acaba de decretar que una franja de 200
metros de ancho a cada lado del muro
será de utilidad pública pero estuve
leyendo en el decreto y dice que son 200
metros O sea que nosotros prácticamente
nos vamos a quedar sin finca no
podríamos seguir con la actividad
Ganadera que es nuestro sustento
Mildred todavía no ha recibido ninguna
garantía de compensación financiera por
parte del Estado por ahora y durante
algunas semanas más podrá compartir un
rato con los niños haitianos en la
orilla del río pero cuando el muro esté
terminado esos dos mundos quedarán
separados este río es el río actualmente
masacre binacional nos puedes contar
brevemente
no me gusta hablar de esa masacre el
nombre hace eco a una página negra en la
historia de la isla en 1937 entre 20.000
y 35.000 haitianos fueron masacrados una
licencia para matar concedida por el
presidente dominicano de la época Rafael
Trujillo los haitianos que trabajaban
para las compañías azucareras americano
dominicanas eran constantemente Víctimas
de racismo la desconfianza entre las dos
naciones nunca se ha extinguido del todo
Nelson e Ignacio son hermanos a pesar de
su edad vigilan sus vacas con el arma
bajo el brazo durante todo el día 5
porque hay Una Pandilla
esa es un asilo de gente ladrones aquí
oyó
sus Corrales se alzan sobre el río
binacional
Yo sé que me han robado 14 vacas para ir
a junta
con tú y becerros serán llevado
conmigo acabaron acabado acabado y nunca
tuve el respeto de de un presidente que
me ayudara hubo que hacer mucha
inversión en paredes vaciado y blog y
columna y Viga por la razón de que los
ladrones toda la noche venían a buscar
vaca
la falta de coordinación entre las
autoridades de ambos países ha dejado
desamparados a los ganaderos frente a
las pérdidas de ganado a unos kilómetros
de ahí haitianos y dominicanos están
mucho más cerca unos de los otros
estamos del lado haitiano en la ciudad
fronteriza de guanamán es viernes día de
Mercado binacional son las 8 de la
mañana en el puente que atraviesa el río
miles de haitianos se preparan para
cruzar los días de Mercado pueden ir a
República Dominicana sin papeles van
para vender algunas mercancías o como
Leonel a buscar trabajo
que no tienen dueño para convencerle a
veces yo la ayudó a vender cuando
comenté estaba cuando vienen los morenos
no es todo lo que sabe hablar creole él
no es todo lo que habla español a veces
Leonel es haitiano pero vivió varios
años en República Dominicana antes de
ser expulsado por no tener papeles la
frontera se abre empieza el flujo de
gente en busca de los mejores puestos
lo único binacional de Este mercado es
el nombre República Dominicana protege
su buena salud comercial aquí los
productos haitianos son considerados
contra bando los haitianos se ven
obligados a comprar productos
dominicanos para revenderlos con
márgenes y risorios lo que asfixia
todavía más la frágil economía haitiana
en este mercado saturado Hay demasiadas
manos pero no suficiente trabajo
por la mañana se necesita alguna gente
cuando llegan uno de trabajo y después
ya no hemos trabajado
como que están los trabajos no hay nada
Leonel tendrá que volver a su casa con
las manos
te gustaría haber comprado algo de
comida en el lado dominicano porque en
Haití los precios se han disparado un
26% en un año Leonel vive con su novia
Elizabeth en guanamá Aquí no hay agua
corriente ni electricidad por la sequía
el pozo está casi vacío
para sacar el agua tan lejos que también
la tanta sogas para que ustedes vean
paga el equivalente a 35 dólares al mes
por una pequeña habitación sin ninguna
comodidad claro cuando yo vivía allá
dominicana yo tenía todo mi casa me
tenía nevela tenía acá mantenía estufa y
el agua también suficiente Lionel dejó a
su madre y a su hijo de 5 años en Santo
Domingo la capital de República
Dominicana no los ha visto desde hace
dos años
balón movimiento va a ver si Dios me por
la ayuda para mmm después pero
seguimos nuestra ruta hacia el sur en el
epicentro de La Isla una carretera
pedregosa separa ambos países a lo largo
de más de 70 kilómetros la bordean
caseríos prácticamente aislados del
mundo en el kilómetro 106 tuvimos un
encuentro particular Tomás Beyblade es
un militar alemán retirado vive aquí con
Elena su mujer haitiana y su hija de un
año y medio
ese caso mío
pero ella no está contento con mi casa
el día Quiero un casa de lujo
le gusta aquí
y a mí me gusta ya
allá muy tranquila y tus allí trabajo
aquí no Y tú puedes vender Aquí no hay
nada
te voy a tener algo no hay venta la
gente no tiene cuarto la pequeña familia
lleva una vida sencilla dedicada a la
jardinería a las sesiones de peluquería
y al bricolaje tomas se ha adaptado muy
bien a la cultura local un ejemplo aquí
entra un ladrón o gente malo y el
círculo en un día dos días tres días en
cuatro días traer un enfermo o
mata el ladrón
Se enamoró de La Isla después de muchos
viajes conoció a Elena y no se ha vuelto
a ir en tres años
con lujo en Alemania
yota llena de ese cosa yo sabía ese no
ayuda por tu vida por tu feliz y mejor
aquí para mí tan pobre así yo no
necesita mucho cosa yo vive aquí bien
con mi pasión de militar Elena pudo
obtener su pasaporte pero él no le da
derecho a vivir en República Dominicana
la vista uno tiene que ponerlo Pero
tiene que poner 4000 400 dólares
[Música]
para ellos un muro aquí no tendría
ningún sentido los habitantes solo salen
del pueblo para llevar sus cabras a
pastar
pero en el extremo sur de la isla donde
la frontera se vuelve a acercar al mar
Caribe la ciudad Dominicana de
pedernales espera el inicio de la obra
para los habitantes de la ciudad
haitiana gemela de la vida cotidiana
todavía se compone de cruces informales
y comercio clandestino
este río es la frontera del otro lado
está República Dominicana miren ese
joven cruzando la frontera casi todos
los días es así
el otro lado hay dos militares en cada
punto
y las personas para poder cruzar sobre
todo por los puntos informales
deben darle algo de dinero a los
militares
no es parte del servicio jesuita para
los migrantes una asociación que ayuda a
los haitianos expulsados a veces
traumatizados por la violencia de las
autoridades dominicanas en este video un
militar dominicano agrede a un
inmigrante haitiano son tratos
habituales en la isla la gran mayoría
del medio millón de haitianos que viven
en República Dominicana está en
situación irregular varios miles son
expulsados cada mes en este barrio de
onzapid son repatriados que cruzan la
frontera clandestinamente cada día por
el tráfico estamos funcionando así como
como ustedes buscando una conejito por
allá por el Santo Domingo para venderlo
aquí para que
ganan ganando la vida todo el mundo todo
el mundo Esa es la forma de vivir
exactamente están acechando sí Sino
agarras se la quitan o le dan golpes
Bueno si tiene suerte pasando bien es el
azul la falta de electricidad en Haití
provocado Un regreso al carbón de leña
lo que explica la importancia de este
comercio ilegal eso no puede salir no
bien porque todo el mundo que está aquí
tiene la vida en la en la República
Dominicana
que no hay más que hace
de regreso al hospital de pedernales
Mira qué tranquilito se ha quedado el
bebé sobrevivió pero los médicos
estuvieron alerta toda la noche
recibimos una cesárea de una nacional
haitiana recibimos dos partos más de
nacionalidad haitiana y un parto de
nacionalidad aquí siete de cada diez
pacientes son de nacionalidad haitiana
frente un bebé
ella sabe hablar español
usted sabe traducir al español hágame el
favor
el recién nacido será transferido a un
hospital especializado
me siento muy satisfecha de todo lo que
ha pasado Dios pero Consuelo no tendrá
tiempo para descansar los pacientes
haitianos suelen llegar en un estado
crítico la inseguridad en los caminos
impide que vayan a buscar cuidados
médicos a la capital Puerto Príncipe Y
el incremento de los precios agrava
todos los problemas
que viene en condiciones de para su edad
se ve se ve un trófica
Haití y República Dominicana entre ambos
países la frontera parece un abismo un
desequilibrio económico sanitario de
seguridad mientras Haití se hunde en la
crisis en todos los frentes República
Dominicana tratan más que nunca de
proteger su vuelo económico impulsado
por el auge turístico
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
recuerde que para visualizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web France 24.com hasta la
próxima